education is very important but for me
going to school was a waste of time
money is designed to make the rich
richer but keep the poor middle class
poorer that's why schools don't teach us
about money the rich don't work for
money we didn't even have clothes
poverty doesn't need to be explained
maybe in some context it does really
what needs to be explained is our wealth
how do we get more of that how do we
generate more of that for everybody
globally money revealed is an exclusive
video series where self-made
millionaires share their secrets on how
they got rich in this episode you'll
learn why schools don't teach you
anything about money how to pick good
stocks to invest in and the simple
strategy millionaires use to pay no
taxes these are the lessons that they
don't teach you in school about making
money and we've partnered with the
series Creator Jeff Hayes to bring it to
you on my YouTube channel
[Music]
enjoy when I found out that we had an
interview set up with Robert kosaki I
was over the moon excited and had a huge
amount of of anticipation but here's
what I didn't anticipate that the actual
interview would blow away any
expectations that I had this is an
interview that I am going to be watching
over and over again for years to come
and I'm extraordinarily privileged and
excited to share it with you right now
Robert I'm really excited to have this
conversation with you so thanks for
being here hey thank you I'm excited too
I feel like there's we could talk for
days about so many things uh you know as
far as the wisdom that you've generated
over the years relative to money and
investment and uh what's wrong with the
system and you know how to how to change
your your perspective of it but how did
you even get started here in the first
place you what got you interested in in
this line of work that you do what line
of work am I in well you're in a couple
of lines of work as I see you're I think
you're a money philosopher I'm I'm an
entrepreneur entrepreneur I have
multiple businesses and uh so so what
got you started on the road to being an
entrepreneur I just didn't want a job I
mean it's uh I just didn't want a job
you know every time my school teacher
says if you don't get good grades you
won't get a job I said good I'm on the
right track because I never had good
grades and that drives a lot of people
crazy because they you know education is
very important but for me going to
school was a waste of time because I had
a rich dad I had a poor dad and my poor
dad was ahead of
education and he was poor because he was
in
education and so I
knew my dad was a PhD you know from
Stanford University of Chicago
Northwestern head of education for the
state of
Hawaii and having him as a father I
realized that if he went to school he'd
probably never be
rich so at the age of nine I raised my
hand in the I was in the fourth grade
growing up in Hawaii Hilo Hawaii little
little sugar Plantation in town and I
asked my fourth grade teacher I said
when will I learn about money and she
looked at me you know she got she was
like a church lady like Dana Carvey oh
AR we you know she goes we don't teach
money at school so I asked her why am I
in school
then and I kept bugging her and finally
I mean and she was like 10 years over
retirement I
think and she got nastier and meaner at
me cuz I just was not years old my
classmates were all rich and I was poor
and I'm going I just want to be rich I
don't want to go to
school and she said to me the love of
money is the root of all evil and I
looked at her I said well my how my
classmates are rich they're not evil you
know what I mean and and the hypocrisy
got to me you know how kids are at nine
sure and so I went home to my poor dad
the head of Education PhD all that stuff
and I said how come they don't teach us
about money at school
and it says because the government
doesn't allow us to do that and so at 9:
I went that's strange do you know what I
mean I just wanted you know kids will
ask questions until they get their
answer
sure and my dad you for Japanese was
tall 6'4 250 lbs and a big man and I
said you know Dad that's really strange
that they don't teach money at school I
said what they teach us to do he says
get a job be an employee but I said
isn't that to work for money he goes
well yeah I don't want to do that I
don't want to I don't want a job but I
don't want to spend life working for
money it's a slave to money MH so
finally he said well why don't you ask
your best your classmate you know your
best friend in school in the fourth
grade because his father's going to be a
rich man someday so how do you know that
he says because Mike my rich dad's son
is an entrepreneur and I went what's an
entrepreneur he says somebody doesn't
need a
job I said I want that job I don't want
a job you know and uh and entrepreneurs
create jobs so that's how I kind of got
started just by
asking what my fourth grade teacher
thought were stupid questions and that
changed the direction of my life so at
the age of nine I began studying with my
rich dad a man who never went to school
MH his father died when he was 13 so he
took over the family
business and in retros what made him
smart his teachers were his accountants
his attorneys his Bankers his real
estate agents cuz he was 13 years old
and he had real teachers I me what I
mean by a real teacher is somebody who's
actually doing the real thing in real
life and as you know most School
teachers don't do the real thing that
they teach right and by the time I got
to the col I went to an
academy and I was flunking out of school
for calculus third three or three years
of calculus and I couldn't do a damn
thing MH and I asked my calculus teacher
I said when are we going to learn about
you know why am I why am I studying
calculus he goes I don't know and I
asked him said do you ever use calculus
he goes no I said why do you teach it
because I get paid
to and I'm I'm a child of the 60s if I
flunked out of calculus it was non-stop
to Vietnam you know what I mean so I had
an incentive to pass calculus which I
flunked anyway
but anyway that's where I kind of got
disillusioned with school education
education is
important but my poor dad was a poor man
although a PhD because they don't learn
anything about money and they don't
teach anything about money in school and
so we wonder why today we have a rise in
socialism and communism and Fascism and
the anger against the rich you know
these these young senators and
congressmen they want to tax to Rich and
charge them send % taxes and all this
and I'm going why are they doing this
well it's because our schools don't
teach us about money and that's why I'm
in this business and it hasn't changed
since you were in school I mean today it
still seems to be the same no it was not
going to change it's really it's it's
it's tragic so and I ask people said
what thees school teacher about money
get this and I said does your teacher
know anything about money they
go do our political leaders know
anything about money
you know there's there's like money is
the root of all evil in many people's
minds yeah but we all use money that's
irony of it is there a relationship
between the banking systems I'd like you
to comment on the banking system and the
educational system well the banks run
the world it's called the central banks
of America you know the fed the uh ECB
the European Central Bank The pblc
People's Bank of China the bank of Japan
we really capitalism is run by a central
banking system MH that's called
communism
also the government is you know
communism is centralized government
capitalism is centralized Banking and
the more you step back you look at the
big picture the ultra Rich control the
central banks for example the Rothchild
Corporation I let's say there's 50
central banks the Rothchild is own about
48 of them wow and so uh you and I don't
a prayer because money makes the world
go
around and the economy runs on money
like it or not so that's why I became a
student of money back in the 80s and I
began looking at my I was a student of
AR Buckman Fuller I guy who created the
jistic domes and all that and he wrote a
book called grunch of giants grunch
stands for gross Universal cash Heist
it's how the ultr rich steal our
wealth and so when I read grunch of
giants is in 8
3 I understood what my rich dad was
telling me as my Rich Dad all you read
Rich Dad P at it says the rich don't
work for money because our money is
toxic our money is corrupt our financial
system or money is designed to make the
rich richer but keep the poor in middle
class poorer and that's why schools
don't teach us about money because the
school system works for the central
banks also so basically the schools are
designed to create workers employees and
employee mindset correct which is I
guess in a part survival mindset you
know you get a job just to provide for
your to work for money yeah and but you
learn nothing about money right IR
ironic isn't it it's uh well look what
would happen if you Enlighten them about
money in school they wouldn't get out
and go work for the bankers nah I don't
I don't know you know I don't know what
would happen but I think the House of
Cards is about to come down anyway
because the corruption inside our
banking system is at all-time highs this
has happened before in his history it's
been going on for thousands of years
where the banking system I'm not blaming
Bankers I like my banker a lot because
he gives me money but anyway the whole
system was ragged by the Banks the
Golden Rule who he who controls the gold
makes the
rules and so I decided I'd rather be on
the banker side than the employee side
it's just a choice yeah so when you came
to that realization then uh real seems
to be your central Focus for your
investment not really okay
okay people think I'm a realistic guy I
am an entrepreneur I have many many
different companies you know I create
jobs I don't have a job I don't have an
office I'm not allowed in my own
company say an entrepreneur is just a
free person that's all it is you don't
ever need money
again and uh yet you're as you said
providing jobs and and you get into
these industries so uh maybe we could
talk about about the bearing activities
but can we start with real estate and
talk about your views of real estate
investment well it's really a business
model you know everybody talks about the
business you know I came in and ask you
about your business model because every
business every entrepreneur has a
different business
model so the model I follow was
McDonald's you know Ray Croc if you read
Rich Dad P that in there my friend
interviewed Ray Croc you know he was at
the MBA program at University of Texas
and Ray Croc asked the class the ba
class said what business is McDonald's
in and everybody says you're in
hamburgers and Ray laughed he says no
McDonald's is in the real estate
business and so when you and there was a
book called a movie called founder yes
with I think Keaton started yeah in
there he expells it out the only reason
you create a business is to buy real
estate now people think oh you're a real
estate guy no that's not true either so
my business so I have I have Rich at
let's say mhm and I
buy probably half a billion dollars
worth of real estate out of one company
MH and the reason I can do that is
because real estate is really about debt
and taxes which they never teach you in
school so you understand the more
profits I make let's say I make a
million dollars in Rich debt I can lever
up I can borrow 5 billion to buy a piece
of real estate so I'm using debt to get
richer most people debt to get poor but
that takes Financial education or
literacy whatever you want to call it so
I buy real estate and because I have $5
million in real estate I pay no taxes so
the real game is called debt in
taxes that's why if you're read Rich Dad
Poor dead the rich don't work for money
I don't have raits I don't have ETFs I
don't have mutual funds I don't have
stocks because I'm an
entrepreneur so how is it that that debt
real estate debt cuz a lot of people you
know you hear them you just prattling
about debt is bad never have debt you
don't want to get into debt Etc you're
advocating it and and for tax savings um
I guess in part for tax savings so how
does that work I didn't say tax I don't
pay taxes well okay so to eliminate
taxes big difference okay so to that
drives people crazy how can you not pay
taxes well you have to understand tax
law mhm okay can you speak to that
yeah tax laws are not about not paying
taxes tax law is incentives so the
government the government wants you to
do certain things for example if you
donate to a church they'll give you a
tax break you donate your car to the
kidney foundation they give you a tax
break right so if I buy a real estate
give me a tax
break monly stuff because I'm providing
housing if I invest in oil wells I get a
tax break because the government wants
energy if I invest in food production I
get a tax break and when I use when I
borrow $5 million to buy a piece of
property I get a tax break because the
government needs me to be in debt you
see if there's no debt the economy
collapses the reason when they dropped
interest rates after that whole Central
Bank the FED screw up they had to drop
the interest rate so guys like me would
borrow you know if they didn't want me
to borrow they'd raise interest rates MH
so they want me to borrow when I borrow
money I create money MH see money is
only created as debt bonds as people
don't they don't teach this in school
yeah so the more I borrow the happier
the government gets because I'm actually
putting money into the economy so I
borrow let's say 5 million I buy a $5
million piece of property then the tax
law allows me to appreciate it
depreciate depreciate sh it and
advertise it zero taxes I collect all
the income from that property
taxfree that's the game is there ever a
a day like in the future that that comes
home the rooster or is it something that
you can perpetuate year over year over
year yeah yeah but you've got to be
smart they'll never teach you this in
school you know I don't know her name
Elizabeth Warren and Camala Harris and
ALC they're all saying let's tax the
rich so if you're over $10 million
income they're going to tax you
70% let me wake people up here you're
making $10 million a year you're not
paying any taxes because you can hire
the best tax accountants and tax
attorneys that the money can buy so they
never tax the rich they attack they tax
the stupid the uneducated the the
misinformed it's tragic and that's why I
wrote Rich Dad Poor dead you know the
rich don't pay taxes legally because the
government wants us to do certain things
they're incentives so when I buy an
apartment house I'm providing housing I
get full tax breaks when I when I drill
for oil I don't buy standard oil or
Chevron or Exxon if I if I drill for oil
the day I drill for oil I get a 70% tax
break the day I drill day one now do
they does does Exxon tell you that
oh well so yeah and and it shows that
these so-called political leaders don't
understand the tax system themselves no
they just think that Trump does well and
I was wondering about this with Trump
because obviously you know he didn't
want to release his tax returns why
should he I agree but they would
probably show similar saying you he
doesn't really pay any taxes because
he's doing what he does in real estate
and probably understands what you
understand it's always in the paper but
the people don't understand what he's
saying yeah there was this article on
the New York Times who was after Jared
Kushner jar gared Kushner is another
Rich Jewish real estate Tycoon family in
New York City who married Ivan K tro you
know all that stuff it's just families
marrying
families sound like U like royalty way
back when yeah aristocracy and so and so
the New York Times this a few months ago
was attacking Jared Kushner because he
paid no taxes and they were painting him
out to be a criminal and all Jared says
I just follow the tax code let me say
this again the tax code is not about
paying taxes the tax code is a series of
incentives say if you donate to your
church we'll give you a tax break you
you grow food will give you a tax break
you produce water will give you a tax
break you provide oil will give you a
tax break you provide real estate will
give you a tax break so if you're paying
taxes you're not doing you're not
helping the government right it's it's a
different point of view that's all I'm
saying I I've always felt and maintained
that that taxes were more about
controlling Behavior than they were
about collecting Revenue right it is
it's like saying hey if you don't do
these things you get punished if you do
them you get rewarded yes yeah it's
really that simple isn't it tax code my
accountant Tom whe WR the smartest guy I
know he wrote a book called taxfree
wealth it's a rich dad advisor book if
you're sick and tired of paying taxes
get the books called taxfree weal wealth
by Tom Wright CPA's my he's the guy that
gu me well so and this is this is where
I've always personally felt the pain
I've been an entrepreneur for decades
now generate a lot of income and I what
I came to realize after a couple of
Decades of working nights working
weekends launching businesses doing
startups taking risks doing all the
things that entrepreneurs do is that if
you if you do that and you make regular
income doing it um by the time you pay
taxes live any kind of a reasonable
lifestyle put your kids through school
you can't accumulate any real wealth
it's impossible taxes just deplete the
the ability to to have wealth
accumulation and I'll give you even
worse advice worse I hate to break the
bad news to you you know so many young
people I'm going to be an entrepreneur
or I'm going to quit my job become an
entrepreneur the moment you quit your
job BEC an entrepreneur you pay higher
taxes yeah you see an entrepreneur will
pay for I mean an employee will pay
approximately 40% this all over the
world employees pay approximately 40% of
their income in taxes small
entrepreneurs pay 65 % you can't get
ahead that way no so rich dad Rich Dad
as a company we educate people about
about the the Big Business site the
McDonald's site as Ray Croc said my
business is real estate so when I come
in here I'm looking at all your
equipment and all this stuff so this is
depreciated at you know pretty good
rates right but if you want long-term
not pay taxes it's real estate well so
you're you're starting so I'm going to
ask you be my Rich Dad for a minute and
and uh so if if I'm a guy and I am that
makes you know pretty high above average
income um has pay high above taxes I pay
a lot of taxes um and and they'll never
tell you that in school no not at all
you know it's always well you know when
you're making that kind of money you
know you can afford to pay more taxes
and I'm like but why do I get punished
for the more I produce the more I'm
punished you know which means that I
can't produce as many jobs I can't
expand my business I can't you know all
those things and if you take the people
who you value create and punish them and
take the people who don't create and
reward them you know it doesn't take
long to see where that might end so I've
logically worked all that out but I've
said but what is the Pivot Point how do
I now go from this and say I I have some
income and I'm I think I'm speaking for
a lot of people who are watching this I
have some income I maybe even have some
accumulated Capital but how do I now
what are my steps to saying I want to
move toward that Rich Dad mentality and
find a way to eliminate my my tax burden
and actually accumulate some wealth well
that's why I said education is really
important but not the stuff they teach
you in
school if you do what they tell you in
school like doctors and lawyers they pay
the highest tax rakes around exactly
that's not that intelligent and they're
the a students yeah the C and D students
like me we don't pay taxes but we we
hire good accountants Good attorneys and
we do what the tax code wants us to do
MH so uh you know when the markets crash
in 200 seven I thought I died and went
to heaven because you know they were
giving real estate away and the interest
rates dropped mhm holy
mackerel you know I I thank you Jesus
you know like you've given me so I
borrowed $300
million and I bought all this real
estate they're giving away and I de
appreciated it I appreciated it and and
uh advertised it so I made Millions to
paid no taxes on debt I borrowed
money but that's what I'm training to do
I I'm not trained as a lawyer I'm not
trained as an accountant I'm not trained
as a doctor thank
God but I did have a rich debt as a man
who never went to school but he was
trained by his accounts his attorneys
his bankers and all that real teachers
yeah not these fake teachers in
college you know in in part if you know
if you're not looking to become a
professional that requires a certain
educational process do you think that
the college education or quote unquote
investing in tuition is is probably not
a good invest it depends on what you
want to become you want to be a doctor I
I should hope you go to med school you
know you want be a real estate at um
broker you got to go to school got to
get that license it's the moment you
have a license you're under the tax
bracket there's a book I wrote called
the cash flow quadrant ESB and the i e
and s has go to school B's and I don't
so the richest guys on Earth didn't
finish school like bees are like
Zuckerberg jobs Gates uh Branson and the
investors like I like Warren Buffett and
uh Soros and all that they don't pay
taxes and isn't it you somebody brought
this up in in the series you because you
have people like uh like puffet who will
say oh you know I I I should be taxed
higher and you know he's making these
public proclamations uh when he's
already got all this accumulated wealth
that he hasn't paid tax on no what he
said is he pays more his secretary pay
more tax than him and I should be taxed
higher and if you believe that guy I
mean I got Santa Claus for
you he is you know he's a very smart man
of course but he comes across as his
Jolly Old St Nick you know he's but he's
smart as a
whip so um he doesn't send his kids to
school either I didn't know this yep I
guess he's got the education they need
right I'm just trying to say something
you know like our school system is part
of the system MH and that pumps out
Harris you Camala Harris and Alexa or
OKC and you know Liv withth Warren and
Bernie Sanders and they're hardcore
communist there's nothing wrong with
being a communist you know but I'm a
hardcore
capitalist so we have enough room on
this planet for both of us but when you
don't give a child a student the choice
and all rich dad our Rich dead company
did was give people a choice say you
want to be an employee or a specialist
like a doctor or a lawyer go to school
you want to be rich like a you know a
what you call Zucker Borg or a jobs and
be like a a Buffett or
Soros Rich dead mhm we're the
5% and that's all we cater
to and we're not very popular with the
school teachers
you've got that right for sure correct
yeah I've uh that's my poor de they're
good people don't me wrong you know I'm
just saying these are your choices here
and freedom is about choice but we're
not given those choices in school well
you know what's interesting because I
think to me in the end you because you
talk about like you said you know your
dad you know skilled academic right and
brilant and probably a beautiful soul
and caring and Etc has a purpose in life
and wants to leave the world a better
place uh so the intentions are all
proper but there's also I think in that
academic SE sector this sort of disdain
for the quote unquote profiteers the
entrepreneurs you entrepreneur was
almost a bad word when I went to school
it still a bad word yeah so uh it starts
to I think translate at least for me
that this starts to become sort of this
this spiritual issue right that that I
believe that you know for the people who
were indoctrinated in the system get out
and they're working and they're taxed
and you know all these things things go
on that I I think it has some sort of uh
adverse impact on the human spirit it's
not just a monetary issue correct you
know there's four different types of
intelligences number one is mental
that's the academic type two is physical
those are the athletes three is the
emotional and four is spiritual and
they're all different intelligences so
those combination of those four makes up
the human being so for me what gives me
the advantage is emotional intelligence
see most people come out of school so
terrified of making mistakes they go
what if I fail I said well if you're not
failing you're not learning it I want to
fail you in school you make mistakes
you're stupid you know in school I was
very Cooperative at test time but that's
called
cheating know I mean everything is
opposite it's like par we're like a
parallel universe e and Ence on one side
bees and eyes on the other and all the
rich dead company does hey look you e
and 's go to school you want to be on
the right side the B and the BNI side
the big business 500 employees or more I
have thousands of employees I provide a
lot of jobs so I pay no taxes I should
get that right you know I don't like it
when I see people struggling financially
I don't like this gap between the rich
and everybody else you know I went past
the 1% long time ago I'll give you an
example in the 60s with I'm a child I'm
a Vietnam era guy I fought in Vietnam
Marine a pilot you know and all this
MH but I fought for capitalism MH you
know I really did I sincerely believe
that in the American dream but we don't
have Financial
education but when I was in Vietnam
there wasn't much of a gap between Rich
poor and middle class you know the rich
had nicer houses and newer cars that's
about it poor guys had chunk junk cars
and junk houses that's about it though
and then it got to be that as capitalism
took off of and provided things so today
the poor middle class they can afford to
travel throughout the world but they fly
on Southwest or discount Airlines so
capitalism provided Discount Travel for
the poor middle class but the rich fly
private jets MH today the rich have
their own rockets and their own
satellites so you know what I mean guys
like musk has musk provides it uh
Branson has his own satellites and all
this so I'm going to have my own rocket
ship I just don't have it yet and that's
the beauty of capitalism yeah you know
for me to have my own rocket ship and
launch my own satellite I better be
doing something yeah now it's a stupid
goal I don't recommend it but that's
what capitalism is whereas socialism
let's take from the rich and give to the
poor it's called Robin Hood Theory I
don't support that CU When I was in
Sunday school I was taught to teach
people the fish not take from the rich
and give them fish right and so that's
where the yeah we separate it's sad to
say what do you think uh if you look
into the future this wealth Gap that
you're seeing that's starting to widen
where's this going to lead us I think
we're going to economic collapse
personally because for thousands of
years we've done what we've done th for
thousands of years what we're doing
today we spend too much money we print
money we debase our currency you know we
we you know during the Roman Empires
they took gold and silver and they mixed
it with lead and nickel and stuff like
this we're doing the same thing and so
the trouble with what's happening to our
money is in 1971 when Nixon took us off
the gold
standard the dollar became debt people
don't know that dollar is debt and they
could print as much as they wanted so
the value of the dollar goes down it's a
very rich dead poor dead I said Savers
or losers cuz why would you save it when
the the FED can print it it it doesn't
compute in my capitalistic mind the
trouble is historically for thousands of
years anybody who's done this collapses
so the Roman Empire collapsed the
Chinese government
collapsed and we're doing the same thing
we just we just don't live long enough
to know it so we're pretty close right
now um we just can't keep printing money
and giving people money for
free and and think that it'll survive
and the trouble is it's now a global
problem you know we have the central
banks of like European Japanese
chines everybody's central banks today
and we're printing money it's not going
to last this is
a you know somewhat uh poignant
statement Savers are
losers because they're saving dollars or
whatever their currency is and that's
all they know yeah and it's all they
know and and incidentally it's it's
promulgated right right you need to save
have zero debt and you need to save and
that's the way you get to your future
and I have 100% debt and no
savings it's opposites it's a parallel
universe wow but but clearly based on
what is happening you know how money is
debased it's clearly you you're you're a
leming walking off a cliff yeah and then
you end up you know pretty broke and you
you've got more life in front of you you
know that and then what's going to
happen is the the Communists are all
going to scream more that we have to
take from the rich and give to the poor
correct scary scenario and the rich are
screwing everybody it's not the rich
it's our education system screwing
everybody that's the problem see I'm a
child of the 60s I remember this quarter
came up and had a copper tinge around it
1964 that was debasing the money and
that's when savors became losers so I
was at a tra uh Antique Show and there
were actually selling quarters for five
bucks because the silver value was worth
$5 now wow and so if you're a savior go
well why is that quarter of $5 now
because your savings have gone down in
value no they wouldn't do that to me I
said yeah they do every day they print
it wow they print money to pay their
bills you know if you and I did that
we'd be in
handcuffs true no I think that's really
a uh a great analogy saying okay here's
a silver quarter five bucks give I get
five bucks for that here's one of those
ones with a copper Rim it's 25 cents
yeah and that's the difference between
saying we're we have a monetary system
that's based on something that's
attached to like silver or gold as
compared to saying H we just can do what
we want to the currency it's got It's
got no reference point and that makes it
worth less and less every single day
yeah and you know everybody watches a
stock market
being a professional investor the
problems in the bond market and the bond
market is bigger than the stock market
so um we're in serious trouble
financially and so that's why when I
when I talk to people I say
buy you know buy a silver dollar it cost
you 20 bucks MH oh I can't afford 20
bucks sit then you got trouble yeah buy
a dime for $2 I I don't I can't afford
$2 it's the mindset screwed up but they
can go to McDonald's and buy a Big Mac
yeah and then hope that the consequences
of the Big Mac on their health is going
to be paid for by the government and
then they'll buy real estate With That
Big
Mac and pay no taxes and use debt to buy
it you know that's why the rich really
get richer and in a sense you know you
say personally you pay no taxes but you
I do what because I do what the
government wants me to do exactly and
and at the same time though you're
causing you through the jobs you create
many you know workers to pay a bunch of
tax so am there you have it right they
have to they have to love you because uh
the the people who are indoctrinated
into the system who go to work for
somebody else to pay their taxes every
single go to school get a job and pay a
taxes save money get out of debt invest
in the stock market and if there's not
somebody like you to orchestrate what
needs to happen for those workforces to
have a job then there's no taxes that
that happen so you're right you're
you're heroic to the the tax collectors
because you create the jobs of the
people that can be tax pay taxes yes you
got it yeah oh yeah I I got it and it's
a system so what would happen if you did
a thought experiment what would happen
if tomorrow morning the workers woke up
to all this kind of saw for what it was
suddenly let's say that they can do a
matrix download you know and they
suddenly say oh I just got the Rich Dad
education you that I never
got does that train transform things in
a positive way what what happens well
it's call it it's it'll never happen you
know like I said there's four types of
intelligence it's mental emotional
spiritual physical and most people when
it comes to money they're emotional
as
they they can't help but spend money
yeah they go to work to spend money and
the difference between you know there
small entrepreneurs and big
entrepreneurs right my job as an
entrepreneur is to create
assets
that's all so when I started I started
the Rich Dad company it's an asset I
never worked there I get a lot of money
all the time from that I buy real estate
I get money all the time then I buy oil
wells I have money all the time and
assets put money in your pocket the
reason the poor mle class struggle is
they buy liabilities they think are
assets let me give you an example you
ask the average person a house is an
asset your house is a liability because
it's not producing any income correct
it's taking money yeah and not only that
you know Rich dead poor dead and so
what's the secret to it it's a book on
accounting that's all it is a simple
book on accounting and they never teach
you Accounting in
school elaborate on that so when you say
it's a book on accounting income expense
asset liabilities statement of cash flow
that's it very simple stuff yeah you can
teach it to a kid but our schools will
not teach it I tried I took it to
Harvard and I got kicked
out the European system of Education
produces two types of people employees
and soldiers people who will do as are
told yeah they cannot
think and they're afraid of making
mistakes and how do you learn if you
don't make mistakes how does a child
learn to walk unless they fall down yeah
but in school you get punished for
making mistakes stupid stupid stupid you
made a mistake and you sit there you
memorize this answer a teacher who knows
nothing about money tells you to
memorize in 1492 Columbus s day ocean
blue you're brainwashed yeah and I got
the only I almost had a hundred on my
tests one time teacher asked what what
was uh Columbus's
Flagship I asked the question which
Voyage I got Hamed for that one W was
cuz there was three voyages yeah and the
Santa Maria went on a ground on
Hispanola on the first
voyage you know but the teacher didn't
know that so she just made me give me an
uh 99 instead of 100 I'm not that stupid
you know but I like history that's why
yeah but I asked the question which
voyage and then I challenged her I said
well Columbus never discovered America
anyway made it to the Caribbean he
didn't make America Pion made it it you
know but most teachers are just robots
they're parents they memorize and they
give it the good people my whole family
is teachers I love them
dearly I go home to Hawaii and years ago
my aunts would say they call me Bobby
Bobby
Bobby have you found a job
yet and I have to go no I have a
job so sorry too bad bad luck I said
yeah bad
luck wow it's just a mindset that's all
it is and it's a
reality so now people are leaning in and
saying oh my goodness I see what he's
saying um what should my next moves be I
I I I have some you know excess Capital
you know beyond what my means to live
with are and maybe I'm currently
spending money on on stupid things I
don't need what could my first step be
toward trying to create some semblance
of Financial Freedom for myself well
that's I said education is more
important than before but you got to
choose your education and what
educational so well it's I I you know I
would I wouldn't go back to school
personally right and you know people say
do what you love I say invest in what
you love MH so there's four basic asset
classes you can invest in number one is
a business McDonald's okay number two is
real estate number three are papers
stock sponds mutual funds ETFs and
savings number four Commodities MH I
don't touch paper at all I don't have
stocks bonds mutual funds or savings
M because I can't control them I can
control my businesses I control my real
estate and I control my gold and oil mhm
that's what I do I'm a control freak but
most people don't have the skill set or
the that's training to control their
assets so when I when people ask what
should I do I said well what do you love
oh I I love real estate so we'll take a
real estate course oh takes money I go
yeah I don't have any
money see I have no spiritual
intelligence and I was just about to say
so and that's where you know the the
sense if you can say out loud that takes
money I don't have money it's almost
like like a negative affirmation yeah
that spiritually now you're you're
you're you're poor not broke but poor as
a mindset spiritually poor yeah somebody
took your heart and soul out of you your
willpower yeah cuz the the entrepreneur
says hey if I lost it all today I wake
up tomorrow morning with my mind and my
energy and I can make it back right and
people you know I'm a marine I did
horrible I did horrible things in
Vietnam as a
pilot and yet I wear this here and this
was a gift from his Holiness the Del
Lama
you know so I'm not Buddhist or
Christian I just believe there's a
spirit beyond all of this and the same
thing happened for me in Vietnam Marine
Corps is a very spiritual
organization you know we gave our lives
so others could live I'm alive today
because dead men kept fighting we have
to do horrible things I me wrong yeah
but it's very spiritual most people
don't have the spirit they they're
emotional their emotions are so over
what if I fail what if I don't have
money you going then your spirit's been
ripped out of you yeah that's the sad
part you know the the doubt almost is
like a poison right to their soul I mean
it's it's like you this doubt of that
you know what if this these
fears um as don't make mistakes if can
make mistakes you're stupid you got to
have money look the
reason the reason I love real estate is
I don't use my money I use my bank money
it's called debt all I have to show the
banker is how I'm going to make money
with the bank's money that's all I have
to do and I what I said is good debt and
bad debt most people have bad debt bad
debt is debt you pay for like credit
card debt your mortgage car payments
good debt is somebody else pays for you
so I have
6,700
Apartments that's
6,700 people paying my mortgage for
that's Heaven kind of interesting thing
yeah you and I pay no
taxes so I I took a real estate course
when I came back from Vietnam cost me
bucks that real that $385 has made me a
multi-millionaire over and over and over
again whereas my friends went got their
MBA they're still fearing they're afraid
of getting fired so try to figure out
how to pay for their student
loan it's just tragic and that's another
thing too because you know with you know
college education how expensive it's got
cuz that's another big debt on the books
right student loans that's not an
accident either talk to me about that
well what happened after the 2008 crash
there was I forgot the name of FFL or
something like this it came in in the
1950s and it was to provide student
loans for needy people but what happened
when the market crashed in 20078 and N
Obama had to cancel it because nobody
wanted to lend money to students right
so Obama changed it and it went through
what we now know as a student loan debt
and the student loan debt that these
kids and so when you have student loan
debts colleges can charge more money
MH the trouble with the new loans that
Obama put out I'm not blaming him but
those loans are the worst type of debt
you can get they're non forgivable you
if you don't pay off that student loan
debt it's an albatross around your neck
forever so the people that get screwed
by that student loan debt our people
either drop out of school and they have
this debt or they don't make enough
money to amortize the debt so right
after the subprime crash in 2008 that's
when these new student loans came in in
2010 and that's why we have a problem
today but they don't tell the students
that and those schools are just sucking
cash out of these poor
students you know I mean it's horrible
what they're doing to students so we had
subprime debt and now we have subprime
education and you're still not learning
anything about money it's criminal what
we're doing it really is cuz they become
enslaved you know go of the debt
somebody's going to pay that you know so
I'm a banker I lend you the money thank
you very much you're going to pay me
forever because you can't default on it
you cannot Bank you cannot you cannot
declare bankruptcy on student loan debt
student loan debt is now the number one
asset of the US government really yes
wow we have we have ripped off the Youth
of our country going to school and the
school Futures are
clueless so it's you get this seduction
as far as saying you know you need to go
to school to be
somebody then we'll lend you the money
because we want you to go to school and
the schools then get greedy in the sense
of saying well they can borrow that much
money we can raise our tuition it's so
bad wow you remember those those there's
a lot of schools today are are diploma
Mills yes do you know I mean you go
there and then they make it really easy
and then you get your diploma and you're
out but they got your money mhm W and
they're not competent students I mean I
have a lot of employees a lot of them
not ready for
anything so it's it's kind of a mess
we're in right now so I sit there and
that's why my little Rich dead company
chugs along and I I love talking to guys
like you and say what I say and then the
teacher send me a hate
mail you mentioned a a book by uh in bck
Mr Fuller uh that you read that had a
massive impact on you was was there more
about him that that influenced your
thinking well again that seems like a
parallel universe because in 1967 I was
schooled in New York I went to the merch
Marine
Academy and there was a thing called
Expo 67 in Montreal so my classmate and
I hitchhike to Montreal to see the
geodesic dome that Fuller built and the
geodesic dome by Fuller was the US
Pavilion at the world's fair but I never
met the guy there and then years later
in the 7
8081 he put on a seminar called the
future of business it was one week long
so I travel Hawaii to California to
attend this one week seminar with Dr
Fuller and it blew my he blew my brain
away
went it transformed me I saw another
world so I think the spiritual side
kicked in versus the mental
side and he had a he had a say he says
you do not belong to you you belong to
the universe your true purpose may be
forever obscur to you but you may rest
assured you're committing your life
you're committing your life to the
highest if you are you are getting close
to your life's purpose if you commit
your life to the highest advantage of
others other words was I working for me
or was I working for others so that was
81 did you feel like you found a purpose
at that point like you get it was time
to work for others at the time I was in
rock and roll making a lot of money you
know I was I had a um I was working for
Duran Duran the police Boy George Van
Halen and all that sex drugs I don't do
I don't do drugs with a lot of sex and
rock and roll it was fun and I was just
making money yeah and when Fuller says
you do not belong to you you belong to
the universe your true purpose may be
forever obscure to you but you may R
rest assured your
if you commit your life to the highest
advantage of others and so in 81 I had
to ask myself what do I know what can I
do as full says I'm just a little guy so
what can we all do as little
people and we find our purpose when we
want to help others we don't we don't
find our purpose when we just want to
make money and that's what I was doing
so I said what do I know and that was 81
then ' 83 his book came out grunch of
giants it was about how the central
banks so the world rip us all off I knew
that game wow I grew up in it I know it
m so then I said I'm going to have to
start teaching so my wife and I in 83
God sad I sold
everything my wife and I went homeless
just to teach and we just kept teaching
what we knew about
money and today we're multi-millionaires
just kept
going so it's interesting interesting
that the purpose drove you and uh to
teach and to teach and I hated school
too is that amazing I mean you know the
irony in it and but then the you know
the outcome as far as you know long-term
you know I guess it's kind of like you
know uh we make plans and God laughs you
know it's like you know I want to
accomplish this by this and this this by
this time you just knew what you had to
do based on something that moved you in
your life you know was I I had no idea
he says your true purpose may be forever
obscure to you yeah so what do I know
and what I knew is entrepreneurship what
my rich dad taught me and so my wife Kim
and I were left Hawaii moved to
California we're homeless and we just
kept
teaching and and as fer says always and
only the nick of time life support
showed
up and Magic happened you know next
person that Tim and I met was John Den
and Bucky Fuller's daughter and you know
when people say how how is it you spend
time with Donald Trump why were you on
Oprah why is all this magic happens to
you because I'm not doing it for me I'm
doing what I know I think I can do what
can I do I'm a little guy and that's
what is lost you know I mean I hate to
say it but so many times like I've run
through a lot of problems my own some my
own business partners all they see me
for
is a chance to make more money and you
don't understand if you focus on what
you can do for others God will take care
of you but you have to be smart
too and you were with your wife
homeless and money and relationships you
know there's there's a big relationship
there as far as what happens when
there's Financial strain in in a
marriage did it bring you closer
together what what happened for you in
in that period of time
well it wasn't easy let me tell you you
know I mean so we we were homeless for a
long period of time but I I already had
some basic skills and then so we made I
was an entrepreneur I made money
teaching and things like this and I just
kept investing in real estate and we got
richer and richer and richer and I kept
teaching and again richer that's what
happened so uh was it easy no it was
hell but I made it stronger spiritually
stronger
you know what they say well if it
doesn't kill you it make well you know
it doesn't kill you you get stronger
unfortunately too many young people
today they're so afraid of being hurt
they get weaker yeah so I'm not too op
optimistic not not all of them but a lot
of them you
know so we got stronger as a couple and
richer and happier and stuff like that
good stuff but it's not been easy we we
had people steal from us Partners R Us
off um
lawsuits but you just get stronger you
know don't retaliate just get stronger
spiritually don't retaliate just get
stronger yeah get smarter and stronger
so then there is this very intimate
connection between being an entrepreneur
and your spirituality like well it
depends on why you're entrepreneur for
us most people only want the money M I'm
going to make a million dollars I'm
going to retire that's their purpose mhm
but my purpose you know I was in rock
and roll I was having a great time my
first take with my wife was to the
police wow you I was in backstage with
the band and all that it was really fun
yeah but once when Fuller touched me and
he
goes he says he asked me one day this
this this is that weekl long program
what's your life's purpose and I said to
get rich and he scolded
me that's the waste of a good mind I
said well maybe for you
but I like my money you know so I use my
money so I I learn I use what I learned
about money to teach others and that's
my life changed and this is the thing
that I think is very important many
times people think there's a um that
material wealth and spiritual wealth are
on opposite ends of a Continuum if you
want to be more spiritually wealthy you
got to move away from Material wealth
and if you want to be more material
wealthy you got to move away from
spiritual wealth but what you're
proposing is that actually they can and
should be winning the same yeah it
depends on you it's called standard of
living I like my standard of living but
I also write a lot about it you know
people say live below your means That's
Not My
Philosophy like um I've had four
Ferraris now now do I need four Ferraris
no but every time I want a Ferrari it's
inspiration so my wife says so I say to
my wife I want a new Ferrari she says
you know the process
the the process is I got to go find an
asset that pays for the
Ferrari to me of my assets pay for my
liabilities and so every time I did that
I just gained more assets and I sold the
Ferrari I still had the
asset you know what I'm saying yes is
that like I wanted this Porsche one time
so I I bought a Mini Storage nothing
down the Mini Storage then bought the
Porsche I sold the Porsche I sld it the
Mini
Storage that's mental you know yeah it's
education well and and it's in a sense
you Ed this term earlier it's a model
like you talking about you know it's a
business model it's just another model
of how you like to uh you know utilize
liabilities that bring you pleasure it's
just a challenge you know I mean some
people like to run triathlons I
don't I'm a rugby player I like uh you
know I'm not a soccer player my rugby
player I like hitting people why don't I
play soccer because I can't hit people
we're all different that's all I'm
saying you know are you having fun yeah
all the time yeah it's such a challenge
every day the biggest challenge is
spiritually emotionally because you go
up and down up and down up and
down and it gets harder to stay
spiritual when you know people are
stealing from you robbing you suing you
they're a lot of them are friends M and
it's how do you do so do you do you have
any uh any practices that you know help
you stay spiritual in in face of all
that meditate I seek uh quote unquote
therapy you know to keep my mind
straight CU I'm a
marine still in there yeah so I to keep
that little Marine in check in here and
the Marines ingrain that there's no such
thing as an ex-marine you could be a
former Marine but you're you're still a
marine yep and it's one of the most
spiritual organizations there is you
know what I mean we're still so tightly
bound when we when I strapped in my
helicopter you know taking off we're
we're five Marines we weren't lieutenant
corporal and Sergeant you know we're
we're five Marines and we gave our lives
so others could live that is spiritual
as a get and I came back from Vietnam I
got spit on yeah you know but it was
still Vietnam was one of the best
experiences of my life still friends
with those guys you know it's a Band of
Brothers
that's spiritual and I don't find that
in business very
often no unfortunately yep well you
spent many many decades and you your own
personal story is is extraordinary and
you're you know you want to see the
world a certain way like like you said
you you certainly don't need to be
sitting here talking to me right now but
you show up and uh there's there's a
reason for all that um did you ever have
sort of a summation what the impact is
you're you're hoping that your purpose
to help other people is like you what do
you want to see is a
legacy as I said you know as Fuller
taught me says you do not belong to you
belong to the
universe and what is and we're all sent
here to do something we all have a
special unique gift something that
happened to us along the
way and it's it's like from the Bible
not really religious either but you know
there was a story of the master who had
three servants and he gave each
of the three servants different talents
now the the switch in there talents is
also money but talents are also gifts M
so we're all given certain talents not
the same
talents and there was that one servant
who did nothing he wasted his talents
another servant bared his talents and
the others multiplied his
talents that was a way of saying give
your
talents but most people don't do it they
work for money yeah they want money
becomes their master and it's really
silly because you don't really need
money to get rich that's why I like real
estate it's my banker's money and it's
my tenants money pay for my banker's
money it's a good it's nice world and I
get tax
breaks I'm in the business of McDonald's
yeah my business is real estate well you
know kind of been summing up uh one of
the things that uh bucker Fuller uh
wrote which I it spoke to me for some
reason I don't know if you have a coming
or not but and I'll paraphrase I don't
know if I remember it exactly but I said
something to the effect of um when I'm
working on solving a problem I have no
thought of beauty but once I solve it if
there's no Beauty in it it I know I
don't have the right Solution that's a
that that same uh statement has haunted
me
forever why so I don't know why I
remember that because I studied with him
three times you know I had the luxury of
studing with three times but he always
talked about he says when you look at a
flower and you see this beauty you look
at a tree you see its
beauty and if it's not beautiful it's
not correct you know and so that's that
statement has haunted me can I share
with you what I think sure um there's
you when I look at the branches of
philosophy in sequence metaphysics
epistemology ethics Politics the last
one is
Aesthetics which is Beauty and if
they're teaching Philosophy for many
many years and thinking about you know
that sequence and how you use it as an
applied philosophy it it I had this
inspirational thought I don't think it
was like not me thinking but just came
to me me came to me and it was that
Aesthetics beauty is really the first
Branch that's where it all starts and
then it emerges from there and you you
look at a sunrise or a Sunset and no
matter what it's it's always beautiful
it always moves you always perfect it's
always perfect yeah and I guess Beauty
and Perfection you know is maybe the
universe is way to speak to us right and
so you know you eart T I read his work
yeah talks about the first flower yeah I
think about that a lot because sometimes
we don't take the time to look at the
flowers and the trees and how perfect
everything is I'm more kind of running
the numbers in my head and things like
that yeah but I think that's the next
evolution is for us going to that beauty
and seeing the beauty instead of just
trying to make more and more
money it's it's a great vision yeah well
thank you so very much really a great
honor to to be with you and to speak to
you thank you I appreciate it thank you
so much Robert kosaki sort of seems like
an enigma doesn't he as much as he talks
about the desire that he had from his
youth to be wealthy how he created the
concept and wrote the book Rich Dad Poor
Dad and all the work that he's done in
his life it seems like well he's all
about the money but what I also found
out is that there's a spiritual side to
his vision for why wealth should be
created and how people can release
themselves from the bonds of poverty and
the bonds of confinement when it comes
to their financial life so I hope you
took a lot of great notes and I hope you
will watch this interview multiple times
like I
[Music]
will well I've got a real treat coming
up for you here the co-founder of the
mly fool David Gardner who founded the
company with his brother Tom
had created a brand that is known
throughout the world in the arena of
finances these guys are smart they're
interesting they're quoted all over the
place they've been out there for decades
and we went to their headquarters and
had one great interaction with a lot of
energy and amazing content with the
co-founder David Gardner so enjoy this
interview David thank you so much for
inviting us into your home or your home
office as I should say but it feels very
friendly and homie here uh looking for
time to say Patrick I thank you for
suffering fools gladly you have to real
we're we're like fools all the time when
actually anybody comes in from the
outside world hangs out with us they're
always raising the caliber here because
you're surrounded by a lot of
foolishness so thank you for suffering
fools
gladly it doesn't feel like suffering
but nonetheless I'm enjoying my my
experience already uh and I just so much
I want to talk to you about I'm like oh
let's let's wait till we turn on the
cameras to have this conversation um
your story is a great entrepreneurial
story so could you kind of give us the
the background like how did this whole
thing emerge sure well we really just
started the mle fool as a newsletter um
for our parents friends uh they were the
only ones willing to pay us $48 a year
for Our advice and I think they just
kind of felt sorry for us and I had quit
my one job that I'd had up until the mly
fool I was writing for Lewis Riser who
was the longtime host of Wall Street
week on PBS he had a newsletter a
financial newsletter published here in
Alexandria Virginia where we're talking
to today and um it wasn't a good job as
it turns out I didn't really get to work
with Lou but what I was doing is I was
writing and I was able to write about
things that I thought would be helpful
for people in the financial World um so
I would write about discount brokers
which 25 years ago was a newer thing
right the idea that you could make some
of the decisions yourself and actually
just buy stocks directly for a much
lower price through a discount broker so
I'd write that up and then it would come
back edited and only half of it was what
I'd written and any color or personality
was stripped out of it and the first
half was just a dry um recitation of
what I'd already said and the second
half were all the reasons you wouldn't
want to use a discount broker and from
one month to the next whether it was
quickin software discount brokers I kept
like not being able to advocate for
something and always without any color
and so I I was out of that job and so we
we had to start a newsletter for our
parents friends but Patrick from the
get-go we've always loved the stock
market we had a dad who taught us about
the stock market and we started to
realize our parents friends don't know
that much about the stock market and so
we we thought we had a voice by picking
a foolish name uh a business grew out of
that how did the name get picked so I
picked the name it was from act 2 scene
7 of as you like it um that's
Shakespeare's probably greatest single
scene about fools and foolishness you
can read all of Shakespeare which I
haven't quite and I don't think you're
going to find a better scene act 2 scene
7 if as you like it but it's a
non-descript quote a fool a fool I see a
fool of the forest a mly fool there are
some other great lines in that scene
like invest me in my mly there are a lot
of good puns for us and what we're doing
but it kind of celebrates a foolish life
which is you're not really with Wall
Street you're out you're you're in the
rural area you're enjoying um the
forests and you come across people who
don't take themselves so seriously and
so I thought that's a great Viewpoint to
be coming from because we are going to
be talking about Wall Street and what
we're doing but we want to make it clear
we're not that we're we're more Main
Street not Wall Street and so I love the
character of the fool we're going to
screw up a lot I've made a lot of bad
stock picks in my life so I can at least
say ahead of time hey at least I told
you I was a fool right I like we know
please we take our work seriously but we
don't take ourselves too seriously and
so I the the name just it fit yeah I'm
so glad we picked it it's a crazy thing
to take it into the financial World well
yeah I was going to say it's it's really
a crazy thing to bring it to the
financial world the opposite of the
newsletter you're originally writing for
right where everything had to be sterile
and clean and serious you right so the
idea was breeding credibility but you're
basically saying hey we're being more
transparent about the fact that you know
this is uh this is not such a serious
game in so far as the you know you're
not Wall Street you're literally on the
other side of that wall metaphorically
speaking Yeah and you could have some
fun with this yes and there's also a
second aspect to it which helps and that
is that once you start to get into
understanding what fools are about you
start to realize they were the only ones
who could tell the king or queen the
truth back in the Elizabethan courts and
back through Renaissance history right
the fool was there he had he or she had
license to be a truth teller at court
when everybody else couldn't and and so
and how did he or she survive well
through humor yeah and so there's one
part of our brand and our name which is
kind of like dummy's guide like dummy's
Guide to Investing kind of thing and
that's that's what we try to do with the
mly fool we try to make it we speak the
lingua Franca use English plain English
and talk to people just like ourselves
and try to help them understand money
but the other part of it is that we
really do try to tell the truth and make
people smarter and use humor and of
course when you're going to take the
name the mly fool and enter the
financial world where people say a fool
in his money are soon parted you know
you you you better have something
special and you better feel really
motivated to own and earn that name over
time well and the brand Purity is here
after all these years especially because
I'm walking around the office and I'm as
I'm looking how the office is set up
what you know what the environment is
around you how the employees interact
either with me or see them interact with
each other there that General Vibe is
all there I mean there's certainly a
sense of of purpose and intelligence no
doubt about it but there's this kind of
just we're having fun vibe going on yeah
and it's something that you can't just
make happen overnight I mean you really
have to any culture is built whether
we're talking about civilizations the
last hundreds of years or we're talking
about a corporate culture or at a
university a lot of us can look back to
our colleges and remember something
unique that felt cultural but I think
especially here at the fool we've just
kind of hired who you hire who you fire
who you promote the cliche runs that
says a lot about your culture that is
your culture so we started by just
hiring our friends from college they the
only ones we could afford to hire
initially we couldn't take out wanted
ads in the Washington Post which is how
you hired 25 years ago these days we
wouldn't have been able to afford a big
LinkedIn package so we just started
hiring our friends and if you're going
to do that then you're going to create a
culture probably by necessity which is
fun right because you're not going to
say things like you need to be here at
9:00 and you have to say till 5: or
we're going to count your vacation days
or all those things the other
corporations do when we started we we
would never have done that that to our
College friends and so we've just kind
of kept that Vibe going you guys have
won some awards around being one of the
best companies to work for haven't you
we have and you know I I credit my
brother number one he's our CEO and Tom
has always had I mean Tom was a great
summer camp counselor he's like one of
those guys that if you went to a summer
camp we went to one in New England uh
you know you'd love to have him be your
counselor and that that love of kind of
a collegial atmosphere whether it's
summer camp or college that feel he's
always done just a great job kind of
projecting that and and and then I I
guess just you know from our name that
we chose intentionally but then right
down through to the business of what we
do every day Patrick which is that we
try to help the world invest better um
you know it's a world that doesn't
understand investing the word invest is
largely misunderstood um we can talk
about that maybe a little bit later but
you know so much of our work is almost
try to peel back the layers of
complexity that people have added to
money that have caused them not to see
the truth or what they should be doing
and so a lot of our our job is just to
kind of get people right back in touch
with hey you're a human I'm a human we
can figure this thing out especially
using the internet together we can
become better at money together so I
think I'm starting to rant or get left
your actual question but it's because I
love talking about our purpose and what
we do you know you didn't leave it at
all and it actually leads to another
question which is so you start with a
newsletter and you know and I think you
said what the intent is having your
parents friends kind of understand this
a little bit better right and have some
fun around it that's true what were the
other milestones in the journey that
started to build out this very large
organization yeah so I think the first
one I'll identify is just that we did an
April Fool's joke um because we were the
mly fool and we did it online which back
then was like a new thing these days
every corporation has its April Fool's
joke annually every year it's like not
even a fun day anymore because
everybody's making but back then nobody
was doing it and the internet well
really the internet didn't exist the
worldwide web that phrase wasn't being
used back in a
19934 right and so we played a joke uh
hyping a penny stock that didn't exist
we started to see people are pumping and
dumping and people are using this medium
to cause others to buy bad penny stocks
and they're literally selling their own
shares to the people that are getting to
buy the stock and and then leaving them
to dry with these penny stocks so we
basically uh parodied that and got the
attention of the Wall Street Journal and
Forbes Magazine Each of which wrote a
little article on what the mle fool had
done on Prodigy which I know we're about
the same age you remember back Prodigy
not a big brand anymore aol's not as
anymore but back in those days they were
big dogs and so so that was number one
is that we got the attention of the
press for what we were doing online
having fun with the medium and trying to
make a really important Financial point
which is don't buy penny stocks and
don't don't get involved in other pump
and dump schemes uh a said hey you guys
should open up the mle Fool on AOL
that's number two that was August 4th of
1994 so it's 25 years uh 24 years later
now but we started the newsletter one
year before so the mle fool is
celebrating his 25th anniversary this
year but that was number two debuting
online keyword fool right getting up on
the AOL main screen back in the day that
was really big we had lots of people
clicking through what is this Jester who
are these people and so we had a lot of
attention and then um we had a great
first month or so and The New Yorker uh
wrote us up in the Talk of the Town
section and said there's this cool new
thing on AOL called the Molly fool and
that triggered calls from Simon and
Schuster from literary agents hey
there's a book here and all of a sudden
we started realizing Two Bros we had
money to a third person and and a fourth
and we could become a company so we very
much did not start as a company we were
not entrepreneurs we didn't think of it
that way but all of a sudden we realized
this is going to become something so now
this starts to build and builds momentum
um and at that point it was information
based for the most part right just
giving out uh your advice as you saw it
there was no product or service that you
were selling other than that in
retrospect I wish we'd had a product
you're right we wrote our first book
Simon Shuster and we basically just said
hey go to keyw word fool on AOL yeah now
uh it was kind of a product in that back
in those days we paid you remember this
connect fees remember $4 an hour so if
you came to the mly fool keyword full on
AOL we'd get 10% of that so if you're
paying AOL 350 an hour we were getting
35 cents if you spend an hour so that so
our first book which tried to help
America think smarter about the stock
market ultimately didn't have any
product or anything that we could really
sell other than hey go to our site all
of a sudden two years later AOL goes
free right going to our site isn't even
now we're just trying to get money on
ads which is how the mle F transitioned
its business during a golden age for AOL
where all of a sudden it got cheap to
get online finally um but but we we
ended up in really bad trouble uh after
2001 which was such a horrible year for
our nation for the stock market which
closed a few days some buildings fell
the uh it was just a horrible year so we
had a lot of layoffs and we had to shift
our business model and we went from an
ad free free ad supported site to a Subs
subcription based business which is how
we'd started seven years before for our
parents friends and now 25 years later
that's how we butter our bread we're a
subscription business I'm reading from
your energy and enthusiasm this is still
as fun today or more fun than it ever
has been after 25 years it is more fun
today than it ever has been I mean the
there are Pleasures that I'll never get
back for example the very first time the
Wall Street Journal ever printed the
phrase the mly fool
seriously I I mean I was on the floor I
was to think that we actually it was a
newsletter for our parents friends
people and we called it the mly fool and
look they've just legitimized us it's
the mly fool says so I can never get
that back right other experiences like
that um having supper with Barbara stren
as she's talking about how she loves the
mly fool and is day trading eBay which
is an earlier stage of Barb tries ex
like just experiences that I could never
have imagined just a year or two before
that when I was just operating from a
small apartment in Charlottesville
Virginia as my wife went through grad
school I couldn't believe what had
happened so I love all that we were on
the the cover of Fortune Magazine when I
go back to the University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill which is where I
graduated University and I say if I
could see a a video of myself right now
with a fool cap on giving a talk to the
business school when I was an undergrad
studying English I'd be like what who
what what a what has happened to me that
I'm talking about stocks with a Jester
cap on in front of the business school
like I so I can never get those moments
back but the truth is that we're
operating at just a larger Base today
and reaching more people and now
globally
we just have more capabilities more
possibilities and that's what's most fun
so I I can say I sure hope Tom's having
more fun than he ever has before I am I
think many of our employees are I'll
never speak for anybody but myself but
I'm having a lot of fun and I think our
members are too and when the stock
market's as strong as it has been you
can imagine that that's going to be fun
too for our business always will be sure
I noticed many of the conference rooms
uh around here have people's names on it
right now we're in the Macky room for
for John Mackey who you know the Whole
Foods uh CEO and and uh co-founder uh I
see Bezos across the way here what's the
theme here so we
definitely um love entrepreneurs there
are no great stocks there are no great
stock picks without great entrepreneurs
so while we're very stock market focused
the truth is we're just very business
focused so I want to make it really
clear that we deeply admire and are
grateful for people like Jeff Bezos I'm
glad that I got to live on the earth at
the time that Jeff did not only did we
pick the stock at $3 a share and now
it's like 2,000 so it's up 600 times in
value so it's been our best stock pick
ever so not only do we appreciate that
but apart from any bragging what an
incredible company Amazon is I mean how
much value is it add just for me as a
consumer maybe you too yes and uh and
then right next to it rolling JK rolling
what an incredible entrepreneur I mean
the author of the Harry Potter book it
just made my daughter very happy
incidentally and you know what I love
about both rolling and Bezos think about
about the smiles they brought to how
many lives in totally different ways and
yet both of them very business-minded JK
Rowling I think the highest net worth
except for maybe Queen Elizabeth uh
female in the UK today and think about
where she came from in fact both Bezos
and rolling didn't come from wealth
right and so that's also a great story
and always been true will be true every
generation about business is that
entrepreneurs rise from anywhere yep and
it's a story of wealth creation right
and that's what I think people have to
understand is that wealth is cre created
um through efforts through purpose
through these types of productive
activities it's value creation that's
exactly right in fact the way I've heard
it before and Patrick I bet you know
this because it sounds very familiar is
um poverty doesn't need to be explained
right because poverty is how everything
started right we arose from the swamps
we didn't even have clothes poverty
doesn't need to be explained maybe in
some context it does really what needs
to be explained is our wealth our
prosperity how where did that come from
and how do we how do we get more of that
how do we generate more of that for
everybody globally so aside from these
conference rooms I'm seeing this open
area work environment here that's
fascinating to say the least it looks
like f i want to go out and play well
it's funny you mentioned that Patrick
because in some some ways both my
brother our CEO Tom Gardner and his
brother Dave Gardner have sometimes
wondered is this the most productivity
that we could have this kind of approach
because it is fun it's very social
there's a lot of glass a lot of
transparency which is true of the mly
Fool's advice and our brand and how
we've always built our company
but it also means sometimes it's almost
too fun so some of our employees have to
sequester themselves sometimes in quiet
spaces or dark places to actually get
work down here at full HQ I don't come
in every day of the week now these days
at the fool but when I do I'm here for
meetings I stack my meetings wall to-
wall across the day if I actually needed
to be picking my stocks or do other
things I might need to find some quiet
spaces outside of anyway it is a lot of
fun and we love it now you earlier
alluded to saying people don't
understand what the term invest means so
so can we Circle back to that and tell
me uh what what you mean by that
statement yeah so the word invest comes
from the Latin investi and I never did
take Latin but I do love um etymologies
I do love seeing where our language
comes from so the word invester in Latin
means to put on the clothes of to wear
the clothes of so a word like Priestly
vestments that's from the same root in
Vester so to wear the clothes of and I
love that visual yes for trying to teach
others truly how to invest because I
think it's a lot closer we're about to
hit the NFL football time of year so if
you're a fan you go to the games people
are wearing the jerseys of the teams or
hockey happens especially in hockey and
football not as much B baseball anyway
people are wearing the clothes and
that's the way we think you should be
with your money when you're investing in
great companies right you should love
what the company does you should see
something of yourself in it you should
be patient when your team has a losing
streak you should shouldn't sell and you
shouldn't be right away thinking now
that I've bought this stock when do I
sell right um You should basically be
making a life time of it as a fan of
capitalism and of the companies that
you're invested in so that's where the
word invest comes from to put on the
clothes of and we live in a world where
the average mutual fund today turns over
70 to 100% of itself over the course of
a year so the average manage mutual fund
today whatever the managers start with
January 1st those stocks are typically
gone by the end of that same year and
while that might work for the
institutions although I don't think it's
a great approach for institutions it
certainly shouldn't be done by
individuals we have an incredible
Advantage by showing patience and by
putting on those clothes it well it's
interesting because the context of that
word is used that way like I'm invested
in my team you know the New York Giants
you know and that's why you would
because you're emotionally invested you
know and and why because there's
something about that that refle you said
this so I'm just reiterating but there's
something something about that you see
there that reflects something in
yourself that you connect to that that
you want to be bonded with so does that
translate into more like you're saying
like a long-term uh kind of uh view when
you're investing you're buying stock
that you don't want to just turn things
over but uh what you advise people as a
far as a part of your investment
philosophy is to buy and hold or be
invested in it for the long haul how do
you see that that's right um I I see
that as the greatest advantage that you
and I have as individuals and more
powerful than the institutions
institutions really have to trade in and
out in part because they have a lot of
people who are putting money in the fund
and then need to pull it out to buy a
house or whatever so institutions
themselves are jumping in and out partly
driven by individuals but you and I with
our own portfolios our 401K plans
there's no compulsion to do that we
should be investing toward retirement or
toward goals that should be long-term
goals and so the greatest friend to us
is the power of compounded returns but I
mean it's just such an incredibly the
math is so beautiful the stock market on
average returns about 10% annualized I
don't know of anything else that does
that I mean that is literally every year
it goes up another 10% now you and I
both know it's not literally every year
some years it drops 28% and other years
it goes up 42% but when you take it on
average over decades or now century plus
it's 10% a year and so if you just let
that 10% keep compounding you know that
you start to double your money every
seven years and that's just if you're
doing what the stock market on average
does now every day at the mle fool I and
my fellow fools work to beat the market
averages I'm happy to say we have a
record of doing that so we can actually
double our money faster than that but
there's nothing like that so the earlier
anybody watching the show finds out
about that in life as early as possible
they get on that that train the
compounding train that 10% annualized
wind at your back and it's so powerful
10 20 50 years later that's why it's a
delight whenever I can talk to a
teenager and when I'm talking to a 50y
two two-year-old like myself I still
feel great like I hope we got another 50
years so let's stay invested but the
earlier we can get them through all the
work that we're doing together the
better for them so it's obvious for the
younger person saying hey you know
there's a lot of road in front of you
and it'd be good to take advantage of
this now but let's say you're the
50-some as you characterize IT
professional uh you've made a good
living you know over time but you've
never understood investment never
understood you know you only understood
how to create you know Revenue based on
the business that you're in what advice
would you have for them say I'm in my
50s now how do I jump into this yeah so
number one um a lot of what you learn
from your professional life can and
should be applied to your investing life
and one of the sad things for me since
there is such a lack of financial
literacy and understanding in our
country and our country is well ahead of
many much of the rest of the world so
there's just Mass ignorance about how to
make your money work for you but once
you realize that the lessons you learn
as a professional can be applied like
what companies do you admire great let's
buy those companies in our portfolios um
let's be numerical we have to be that in
our business well did you know you know
that whole 10% thing I was talking about
earlier let's do some math on a
spreadsheet together and put together a
plan and and let's so so number one you
have more than you think which was the
title of our second book all those
lessons and viewpoints you have both as
a professional and a consumer right and
the people around you some of my best
stocks come from my kids my wife my
friends my fellow fools I don't have to
be a genius and find every good company
out there I can definitely listen and
socialize it right so number one then
number two um you we're all living
longer these days I mean a lot of people
have the biggest fear not that they
didn't save but that they're going to
live so long that they're going to
outlive and outstrip their savings
because of the increase in longevity ity
um worldwide longevity for humans is up
one3 in the last since 1950s so
basically the last 80 years we're all
living onethird longer than they did uh
just a generation or two ago so so um as
a fellow early 50s person if I'm
speaking to somebody like me because I'm
52 I'd say you should be thinking about
40 years ahead does that sound like a
long amount of time to me that sounds
like the long term that sounds like a
good healthy amount of time so let's get
invested now let's take our savings
right away and get it in the market and
and we can talk some about the market
and it's Wilds but you know let's not
worry about what the Market's going to
do tomorrow let's not worry about people
telling you it's going to crash next
year those kinds of things think about
being an investor for the rest of your
life 40 plus years and let's start doing
it the real way the way that works so
let's talk about the market so uh what
what comments did you have in your mind
when you were saying yeah we can talk
about the market what do you want to say
about it so a couple rules of thumb
everybody should know um we've already
covered One stock market Rises on
average 10% a year it's very hard to
find anything that's going to do that
real estate depending on where we are
might do something like that but it's
really it's illiquid you can't turn
around and sell that property and you
have to maintain or be a landlord that's
a that's a lot of effort relative to
just a stock portfolio um bonds 56 7%
historically um you know CDs 1 2%
historic I mean so uh the state lottery
minus 50% I have to put a quick slam
into the state lottery CU it's really
bad advice that we're giving our fellow
Americans every day things like you got
to play to win you could be next it's
really sad every dollar that anybody
spends on a lottery ticket 50 cents is
skimmed right off the top as a tax and
you're left with an incredibly it's a
it's a bare Market every day in state
lottery so people lack an understanding
of these numbers and so I just like to
make sure we understand kind of uh the
range of possibilities there's minus 50%
daily right up to how about 10% annually
overtime so another rule of thumb two
years out of every three the stock
market Rises one year out of every three
the stock market Market drops uh so if
you're going to hold as I do for decades
that means a third of the time you're
going to feel bad you're going to look
silly as a professional picking stocks
that people follow my advice I look like
an idiot all the time a lot of the
stocks that I picked haven't worked out
and so you just have to be at peace with
that and recognize you need to lose to
win so let's say I'm a subscriber of
yours and maybe a new subscriber um
what's the best way for me to engage so
that I can maximize the benefit I get
from your service so mly fool stock
adviser is our
starter service that's the vast majority
of our members are subscribed to mly
Fool's stock advisor and what we're
doing there is my brother and I are each
picking a stock a month and so we're
thinking about the next three plus years
so if you were to join this month you're
going to see my latest freshest newest
favorite pick right my brother Tom's we
you you'll be able to look up and down
and see all stocks we've ever picked
since we launched in March of 2002 MH so
you can see our records you're going to
see we've beaten the market very
substantially in a world where it's
often assumed or taught that you can't
beat the stock market it would just be
luck right for some reason I've happened
into the one professional discipline
where everybody thinks that it would
just be luck to be better than average
people don't think that about NBA
players they don't think that about
doctors or lawyers but for some reason
you know picking sucks well that would
just be you're coming against monkeys
and you have no shot throwing darts
against the wall right so I don't
believe that I've never believed that I
think that you do you are rewarded you
definitely can beat the market we've
demonstrated that so you'd see that in
stock advisor and then we we would want
you to to to get your feet wet we we'd
suggest that you buy one or both of
those stocks and then next month when we
come out with our next pick we'd suggest
you do it again and make a regular habit
of saving every two weeks investing
every month and I'd hope that you could
go from zero stocks if that's where you
were to 15 stocks right as quickly as
possible so that you have a nice base a
portfolio and from there you could keep
adding or just add to those 15 you could
add more there's a lot of ways to play
it but what you're doing there two
things you are investing regularly right
you're not sweating the market or
worried or waiting because you hear it
might crash every single month your
dollar cost averaging into our picks and
number two you're going to start um
experiencing the positive vibe of
success because again 10% on average is
the gain made by this thing year in and
year out and two years every three
you're winning and it beats everything
else especially over time so I think
you're going to start feeling those
Positive Vibes and you're going to want
to save more at that point you're start
saying honey let's save even more cuz
look and and in fact you'll be rewarded
for that over time so structurally it'd
be a matter of saying okay so I I would
uh follow you know subscribe I'd set up
some kind of a trading account ah yes
yeah you would definitely want to open
up a brokerage account which these days
very easy to do online and things like
Schwab and er trade and you see them all
advertising and they're all pretty good
y um but yes you definitely need to have
an account and that's not much more than
when you open up a bank account as a
high school kid you probably wrote a
check to deposit that first amount of
money you do the same thing with a
broker account of course a lot of people
have 401k accounts and retirement plans
IAS where they can invest sometimes
stocks directly there so a lot of people
use that and but and I think a part of
this which is uh maybe the the the the
psycho psychological part you know this
this human psycho dnamic is saying well
once you have a structure then you start
to have the discipline to fund you know
as a process saying hey you know we have
a certain amount of income coming in and
we're going to allocate and that's right
and doing it with you you know cuz just
hearing you talk about it being in the
you in the glow of of what this
environment is here it seems like fun as
compared to drudgery and I think that's
a part A lot of people say this is too
abstract and mystical for me and it
seems very boring I don't want to you I
don't want to get involved but somehow
you guys keep people engaged through
through humor and through fun well I
appreciate that and um because I don't
want to take I don't want us to take too
much credit for it I think it is among
the most fun and positive things that
you can do whether or not the mly fool
ever told you to do that or not right
right the act of becoming a part owner
of companies that you admire companies
whose products you love a lot of people
love Apple it's been a pretty good stock
over the last 10 or 20 years right it's
now the largest public company in the
world the first trillion dollar company
that's right and it's been tremendously
successful and a lot of people the
reason it's so successful is because
they love the product and So for anybody
who ever bought an iPhone I'd say did
you think about also spending that same
200 bucks saving additionally buying
some Apple stock because that iPhone is
going to depreciate you're going to have
to buy the next one but the at Apple
stock that appreciates so to to to go
away from the stock market briefly you
know a lot of people buy that first car
and they don't realize that's going to
be a depreciating asset it's maybe not
the best way to spend your money if
instead you'd spent that money with a
$30,000 stock purchase and you play that
forward 10 15 years you start to see the
power of not buying car is new that
often so so I think it should be fun I
think it is fun I love the companies I'm
invest invested in I'm fascinated by
intuitive surgical which is bringing
surgical robots and improving outcomes
for people or Netflix which is the way
I've spent a lot of hours right these
are companies I love so I think this
should should be by Nature fun and maybe
a lot of people like fantasy football I
like fantasy stock ball I think that we
should have the same fun that people
have with watching sports with our
stocks you know and it's interesting so
often uh over the years my mother had
like she like when we were having to
have traffic directed to go into a Whole
Foods you when it first came out in our
Town she's like you ought to go buy that
stock you know Home Depot you ought to
buy cuz she just these crowds and and
and back then of course I was smarter I
went and I looked and I said well you
know looks like all the growth is priced
in already blah blah blah that's when
whole food was like 20 or something you
know and so my mom actually was a much
better stock picker than I was
appreciate that but I think that's the
point is what you're saying is that if
you're a consumer of something that you
have a passion about that's probably a
good stock to be in you know given some
other you know considerations but that's
one way to look at it absolutely in fact
that's the truth way of looking at it
the reason that the stock market exists
is so that people like you and me can
take part ownership in the companies
themselves they take in our money and it
allows them to grow their business but
we become part owners and so it's it's
amazing that every day you have access
to thousands of companies that you and I
could right now become a part owner of
and then the only question is a do I
have the money am I saving am I saving
10% of my salary every two weeks I hope
so Y and then B okay which one out of
this kid and Candy Store Farmers Market
here which Booth do we want to go up to
we're not going to be buying fruits and
vegetables we're actually going to be
buying Hasbro right or Disney right or
Under Armour and why would we buy this
one over that one and which is going to
be the best one and the if you're a
gamer and I'm a gamer like I'm not even
an investor I'm really just a gamer who
happens to invest if you're a gamer this
is like the greatest game of all is
asking what's going to beat the market
what's going to be the best what's going
to be the next apple that's one thing we
do every day at the the mly fool and
over the last 25 years we've gotten it
right some of the times and it's
tremendously fun when you do so what are
conversations like around here because
I'm sure you have a team of people that
are looking at different things and you
probably get together and say okay let's
let's uh have a conversation what do you
think what do you think what do you
think and people kind of share their
passions or their ideas as far as what
stocks you know what's your process like
yeah well and that's just that's that is
true of what happens here at full HQ
especially among our analysts that's
their professional calling um but I mean
with member event and and people on our
website and the community that we've
grown at at fool.com over the years I
mean we basically love those
conversations it's again it's kind of
like that if you do a fantasy football
draft except we're talking about stocks
and the good news is while it's fun to
win your draft NFL league when you win
with your stock portfolio that really
causes your life to change in wonderful
ways like you can retire early off this
harder to do off that right so so we
recognize the importance of these
decisions and we try to make sure that
everybody whether they just started as a
receptionist here at the mle fool and
you'd think well that person maybe
wouldn't even care about stocks no
everybody we want to make sure that they
love what we do now not everybody's
going to care about the stock market as
much as my brother and I do right but
but that feeling of well the purpose of
our compan is to help the world invest
better so darn it we should start with
our employees in fact we give each of
our employees a stien to begin investing
regardless of what their role is but
yeah I I think that um shows like
Silicon Val I mean just think about how
business is more and more popular the
office right like these are entering our
narrative our stories as storytellers
like these things that were cluggy stock
market conversations 30 years ago so so
I think being interested in where the
world's headed and it's being shaped by
for-profit corporations globally in my
opinion most strongly of all you're
talking about the future as much as you
are some wonky thing like the stock
market right and it seems to me like
you're giving people new lens to look
through when they're viewing the market
like just to have a different experience
in what they what they're seeing um what
do you what do you see moving forward as
far as mle fool and what's what impact
it might have on the world let's say in
the next 10 years what do you want to
see happen well I would love for
everybody to be invested and for that to
happen everybody needs to save and we've
tried various things over the course of
time at fool.com our book you have more
than you think we've written to the
people who don't have money yet and who
who can invest in the stock shouldn't
they have credit card debt got to get
rid of that a lot of student debt these
days we we've tried to speak to these
and help people there but the the future
that I hope that we're helping create is
one where everyone's a Savor because
everyone truly can be and then they're
using that Savings in a way that they
enjoy not everybody is going to want to
invest directly in stocks we know that
um so they can go for index funds or
have friends do it for them but in
particular we're creating a world where
the people who do want to make a choice
it doesn't have to be all of your money
money but buy your first stock they
start to see the fun and participate in
capitalism capitalism is the most
participative um system that I can think
of everybody is a buyer or seller
everybody's trading we're buying from
each other you're really good at doing
TV shows I hope I'm not horrible at
giving stock picks here we are trading
right where each so it's such an awesome
system everybody should be on board and
conscious capitalism which is something
we could or could not talk to I know
Patrick it's part of your background
John Mackey is is a founder of the
movement but I mean so I think
everybody's doing that and that's what
the mle Fool's working toward and when
more people are participating in
capitalism then which stock You Pick
starts to matter even more like what do
we want to fund what's going to win
what's going to lose let's make sure
that we're betting on the right horses
and that we feel in touch with the
purposes of the companies one thing we
never do at the Molly fool is we don't
advise people buy companies that they
don't respect the products or Services
we don't think hey it'll be a good stock
but you know they they sell tobacco so
just buy it but you know it may not be
good for the world no we we're we're
like your money should be exactly
aligned with what you think about the
world in fact if you really care about
socially responsible investing one of
the most responsible things you could do
is become a direct investor in stocks
and not just give it to some fund
manager who's making that decision for
you so I see a world that's more and
more in touch with a proliferation of
innovations that are for-profit
companies and more and more people
interested and excited maybe slightly
less fantasy football I feel like I'm
pounding fantasy football for no good
reason this interview maybe it's just
that time of year but I think too many
people care about sports and not nearly
enough people care about their Financial
Freedom and I know the value of this and
I love this too but it's like that and
that's the way that's the society the
mle fet hope is helping it create with a
group of my entrepreneurial friends uh
we are putting together a book called
the moral virtue of capitalism where
each of us are writing to that because
the Practical aspects of of capitalism
are foregone conclusion but you're
actually starting to speak to the moral
virtue of capitalism so can we dig a
Little Deeper there as far as how you
see that this system is really the right
system and how human beings should live
together and trade together well it's
the story of humanity in fact a
wonderful book called the rational
Optimist by Matt Ridley he talks about
how um what makes us unique as a species
is we trade we trade goods we trade
ideas we trade experiences we trade
across cultures from the dawn of
humanity we started to rise out of the
swamps with many species weren't because
we traded and more than anything we
traded ideas because I think it was
Thomas Jefferson who said you know an
idea is like a lamp that's lit and I can
light yours from mine and I lost nothing
and you gain something and that's the
story of capitalism when we work
together when you do something you're
really good at and I do something I'm
really good at and we buy from each
other we both got a better quality
product across both of those experiences
and the world starts to specialize and
that's obviously what's happened America
probably practices the highest most
advanced form of capitalism at scale
today and yet we still see so many ways
that it could be improved and will be
but it's still such a great system
because at the heart of it you have
people doing what they love and do best
I hope I hope we're all doing jobs that
we love and if you're not and you're
watching Patrick and me right now change
your job I had one job before when I
started the pool and I hated it and I'm
so glad that I walked away from it at
the time but but so we should be doing
something we're good at that we love and
then we should be buying that thing from
other people and and then we should
start corporations together and be
invested together and then watch our
stocks triple or go up 300 times in
value like amazon.com I'll close my
answer by saying that how did our dad
get us started with the stock market he
said hey kids look we're in safe way
here in Washington DC at the grocery
store chocolate
pudding we own some of the company that
makes that chocolate pudding we own some
stock in them just a little bit let's go
get more chocolate pudding so it made
him an awesome dad cuz we're like s
years old being told that we we should
be getting more chocolate pudding but
that's that's capitalism and it's a
beautiful thing uh well practiced which
it is increasingly today well and that's
a perfect metaphor I think for what
you've done is that you're you know the
mly fool has brought to the world the
idea of getting more chocolate pudding
making it fun so somehow that little
lesson from your father all those years
ago has manifested touching millions of
lives you around the world in a very
positive way and I think what
extraordinary is that you've you've
injected vitalism life into something
that was seen as a very kind of dry
marble facade uh you know staunch uh
boring thing you've turned into
something fun you turned into something
that that not only is employing people
that are having a lot of fun with it but
it's touching millions of lives out
there so I know you're extraordinarily
busy in the fact that you would take the
time to sit and talk to us is it's just
a testament to how much you really care
about getting this word out there and
getting your message out there there so
thank you so much for spending this time
and uh I wish the mly fool many many
more Decades of of the foolish behavior
and fun that you're having thank you
very much Patrick and thank you for
featuring us on your show in this series
I think it's great what you guys are
doing which is that you're trying to
help all of us understand money better
it is such an important subject it's
often not taught in schools even at the
University or graduate level and yet
every day we're loosing new adults upon
the world yeah uh who are going to have
to make decisions the rest of their
lives about money and it's going to
matter a lot so let's keep spreading
that thank you so much thank you great
to be with
[Music]
you I really hope you enjoyed episode
one and one thing I want to encourage
you to do right now is to share this
with anybody else in your life that you
think would benefit for sure children
should be watching this information
they're not learning this in school
maybe your spouse maybe your co-workers
maybe brothers sisters Etc but share
this this topic of money is a critical
topic for all people and as you can see
after episode one there's a lot here to
learn and we have so much more coming so
please share this I look forward to
seeing you in episode two to see the
next episode in the money revealed
series check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there value
creation is the engine for exchange
exchange creates wealth the more we
exchange with one another the more
wealth it's created and a dollar doesn't
end because I spend it you take that
dollar